once upon a time there was a Kingdom
full of flowers and rain bills where the
Sun shone all the time and there was
loads of that goody-goody lovey dovey
good people stuff going on there the
Alliance of abominably good people lived
in unearned wealth and prosperity but
there was a path leading to a different
place there at the end of this path was
a rock there was a cave carved in this
rock in which the absolute evil lived it
wasn't a grubby damp cave smelling of
Maca mildew but a deep dark dungeon so
dark that even darkness itself was
afraid of it it was home to numerous
innocent monsters who enjoyed a happy
contented existence living in complete
harmony with their environment but time
and again the sickening sweet smelling
good visited this underworld in search
of treasure and experience points many
monsters found this to be the death of
them but much worse the absolute evils
treasures were being stolen one day just
as a few more heroes had finished
plundering its dungeon the absolute evil
decided it had had enough and decided to
do something new something quite
monstrous go to the service
the Alliance tried to resist but the
approaching horde just flowed over them
like an angry wave of axes teeth and bad
breath after numerous unrelenting
battles the absolute evil finally stood
before the Alliance's capital Kings
ending all right so whatever drops you
into here this is actually a skirmish
map so there's multiple game functions
that you have here in dungeons
you've got single-player campaign which
is the main story you've got multiplier
which is skirmish map so it's dungeon
Lord against dungeon Lord and whoever
you know in a sense you know captures a
flag controls the most territory on
vanes the other person's dungeon you win
and you can set parameters for that you
know or you know in some of the DLC
packs that are included on the ps4
version you get all new skirmish maps
and so forgot
you know ones that are themed we've got
a song of sand and Fire a clash of
pumpkins which is very Halloween theme
where you fight ghosts and I believe
this one is actually from a class I know
this is one of the downloadable skirmish
maps so I've kind of moved this along so
we've got our brewery always crucial
here we have what's called the sort of
the Goblin tech room this is where he
would do research so these are all the
traps so he's building up units to build
the traps this is the trap machine
here's all the traps that he could
probably want to research and has
already done so we've got exploding
treasure chests tar pits to the right
then we've got swinging maces spikes to
pop up a swinging axe boulders cuz why
not and some you know drop some
lightning to toe so you get powerful as
more time goes on so these guys are
working on that got a rather expensive
treasure room got another rather
expensive treasure room over here so
we're rolling in it you know and what
you'll see here this one hasn't been
actuated yet but what we've got is later
we get instead of orcs we also have
Nagas so at Naga
are these characters up here these are
your range fighters and also your spell
casters so while they're doing is
they're made they're mining mana and
some mana feels not only the magic
spells that you can have for traps but
also the dungeon Lord gains the
abilities to have spells later that
effect not only within the dungeon but
later outside the dungeon so when you've
got your forces out there you know
you're ready to go all right so haven't
played it all the way through this so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna start
getting as many you know strong folks as
we can we'll let that power up here and
we've already got six orcs and screen
Agha we're just gonna make sure
everybody's doing okay and after a while
you know the enemies will come in so you
know you're the ultimate evil you've got
a dungeon full of treasure heroes can't
resist it so they'll keep coming in I am
but you got to setup the defenses so we
got spike trap and then we got explody
treasure bomb and those all work out and
then what we're gonna do we're gonna
take this fight to the overworld real
quick it's actually hoping someone will
come in for a second and just to make
life easier so we're gonna go you know
we're gonna pick up let's say let's grab
her well drinking a beer all right yeah
you're it's over and let's just get oh
I'm glad you'll notice each of these
guys have difference in a minute that's
consistent throughout the entire game so
no you can't you can't assign names to
them but they do get their own names and
keeping with a humor you'll find one
that may or may not resemble the name
Katy Perry it's actually pretty funny so
there's a lot of like subtle humor stuff
and so here we're gonna go here's our
first outdoors so yeah you do have to
pick everybody up and then boom now you
notice on the bottom left of the screen
this is the outdoor map so now we're
moving on to different Maps your your
dungeon still going so you gotta go back
in here and you're back in the dungeon
and got to keep an eye on stuff but now
you've also got to manage your folks who
are out in the cold
alright one of the parts of this is
penguins are your enemy you're fighting
in the Arctic and this is like this is
part of the bonus DLC that is included
on the disc holiday themes all right
we'll send them up there when they're
done oh no all right so yeah you can do
group or you can do range and you can
switch between deselecting and rotating
through all the different folks
so they'll Auto Attack and like I said
it's more like you know it's a Warcraft
you know you can you can strategize
between ah there we go the clash of
pumpkins you know you got to watch out
for penguins because they're feisty but
back in the dungeon you know this is
where you would keep maintaining things
so now the balance that you have to find
in the game is now I've already beef
this up this is top level 3 this is you
know like easy level what's gonna happen
is the enemies will continue to come in
and as you excavate because you need
more rooms you're going to need to dig
out for another treasure you're gonna
need to be able to dig out and find more
manna you're gonna need to build farther
along these walls and go out here and
build infirmaries training rooms etc to
that the point where all of the stats
and abilities that you have for your
overworld people who are chillin up here
oh not doing much need to attack some
penguins are supported by the dungeon so
you know that's what you think about it
you send them out and home
right now the more you take these guys
down and they're a little sort of igloo
spawn units onions are pretty tough this
guy's got to go Oh enemies in the
dungeon where they over here yes Oh see
the Penguins coming in they hit a bomb
Oh Oh goblins attacking them here comes
some spikes here comes an org Oh more
spikes and no your traps don't affect
you otherwise you never get out of the
touch these guys are getting creeps on
this they go see so without traps you
like you'd have to have a like a massive
amount of orcs and then come in here and
pick them all up
you know once the once the alert goes
off they could run over there but the
traps slow them down and there we go all
right sweet so we're like you were good
and then the guys will just bring over
the units which were being built here as
you see and start rebuilding the traps
there's an automatic process but this
comes later in the game level 3 like you
really have to XP a lot and you'll
notice up here you see that this you
know those are snots those you're just a
function guys then you've got your
goblins right here these those are more
of his assassins and also researchers
and then you've got magic and ranged and
you've got your retained two browsers
and then you get on the right which is a
little dark day out right now because
we're not high enough level is like the
super work you know the big bruiser and
it gets pretty in-depth so this is kind
of what's going on here and we'll just
see how these guys are doing just
killing Lord penguins not doing much huh
Oh everybody is dead Oh see this is why
you've got to make sure that you're
paying attention there you go yeah up
see my party is failed the Penguins have
won again so here we are this is
actually the last dungeon of the
campaign so this has been built out I
mean we're talking hours and hours and
hours we've got one you know here's our
exit to the outside this is the final
battle revisited you know Kings ending
right so we've got our traps some pretty
crazy traps oh look at that you know
there's just kind of pop out and you
could sell that you know I've been
putting a lot of effort into here you've
got crazy doors on you've got electrical
things cause the whole like sweatshop
you know I got money for days this is
kind of just give you an idea of like
this is where you're going towards we've
got training units so you can build into
the like I said my gigantic massive
Mekkatorque dudes
this guy's there you go
let's pick him up see what he's up to
yeah yeah not the most pleasant people
you want to run into all right so we're
just like you can just chill out there
so we've got our Nagas minded magic
we've got advanced Nagas it's just also
pretty slick they're going to town on a
bunch of stuff and this is just to give
you Cora concept of like where we're at
right here I mean this is on the bottom
right we're looking at a ton of real
estate here all of this powering up your
your gold level your mana level just
about everything and so let me skip
around is my dungeon would be R always
be R go people just chillin I got this
guy just sitting there getting fat fat
bruiser I'm sorry it's a rather large
bruiser all right cool see and that's it
this is the battle that you want to get
to and then here we go we've already
cleared up this entire level we've evil
fide all of it ready to get to the end
story we've got to take down King
Roberts
but unfortunately you guys are gonna
have to wait to see what happens after
because that would be the end of the
game there you go but that's it that's
kind of the idea what you want to do and
it's like I said it so you always have
to keep an eye on what's going on down
in your dungeon because as you saw
previously you know you have to have a
good amount of strategy and support or
penguin
hang on zone Oh kill your party